وينضم الينا من بيروت ناصر ياسين وزير
البيئه اللبناني في حكومه تصريف الاعمال
مرحبا بك سيد ناصر
انطلاقا من ما تبعناه في هذا التقرير
هل اسقط في يد اللبنانيين جميعهم شعبا
وقياده وحكومه ومسؤولين عن ايجاد اي حل
لاي مشكله في البلد مهما كانت صغيره
اشار الى
الازمات المتعدده التي تعصف بالذهان ولكن
ايضا اشار الى بعض الامور الايجابيه التي
قامت بها حكومتنا خلال السنه الماضيه هناك
تاسيس
لمرحله تعافي كانت يجب ان همم تكون اسرع
من ما حدث خلال الاشهر الماضيه
وضعنا بعض الامور على السكه الصحيح منها
الاتفاق
الاولي مع صندوق النقد على مستوى الخبراء
اللي كان لازم بشكل سريع خلال هذا العام
بعد انتخاب مجلس النيابي يصير في تنفيذ
لبعض الاصلاحات واصدار قوانين تضع لبنان
يعني همم مرحله التوقيع
الاتفاق النهائي مع صندوق النهار لان هذا
اساسي ليس للدعم المالي الذي يحصل عليه
لبنان وسيحصل عليه لبنان عندما يوقع ولكن
ايضا اشاره الى المسار الاصلاح الذي يجب
ان يتبعه لبنان كحكومه وكما يعني انت تعرف
ان هذه ليست الخطه الاولى الاقتصاديه
وليست تفاوض الاول مع صندوق النقد وهناك
قوانين عاجزه لبنان عن اقرارها وماذا لا
يحاول ان يقرها لن ندخل في في هذه
التفاصيل لكن عمليه
لم يكن هناك حل لاي مشكله بل ان المشاكل
همم تعقدت وتعمقت اكثر الى حد العتمه
الشامله مثلا في في البلاد وصولا الى
العجز حتى عن انتخاب رئيس
اللبنانيون يقولون نريد تدخل خارجيا
الجميع يتحدث بهذا المنطق فهل هل الجميع
ينتظر مبادره خارجيا للحل
لا المبادرات الخارجيه تساعد يعني خليني
افصل شويه موقفك استاذ العزيز ليست الامور
يعني بهذه السوده كما كما تقول هناك اكيد
مشاكل وكلنا نعترف بتعدد الاسماك وصعوبه
حلها ولكن يجب ان نفصل بين عده انواع من
الاسماك على راس السنه هذه الازمات في
لبنان هناك ازمه سياسيه يجب نتفق على ذلك
هناك غياب لاستقرار السياسي الذي يؤدي الى
صعوبه وضع حلول لكثير من القضايا منها
الكهرباء ومنها ما يتعلق بالموضوع المالي
والنقد والمصري ولكن يعني وضع كانه لبنان
انتهى كما تذكر صديقي العزيز يعني ليست في
مكانها وليس بالتحليل العلمي مع تاكيد على
صعوبه الوضع والازمات التي تمر بها
والمحاولات التي نقوم بها جميعا للصعود من
هذه الاسماء ولكن يعني لب هذه الازمه في
لبنان هو ازمه سياسيه هو عدم قدره
التيارات والاحزاب والفرقاء والقتل الان
في مجلس النواب على
القيام بابسط الامور بديهياتها وانتخاب
رئيس الجمهوريه ضمن همم الاوقات الدستوريه
يعني خلال اسرع وقت خلال هذا هو الاساس
فنحن يعني نحاول تهدئه الوداع ابقاء بعض
القطاعات العمل مع المجتمع لبنان على
الاعمى على المنظمات
لماذا لا ينجح لبنان
همم بانجاز اي امر من دون تدخل خارجي يعني
حتى تشكيله همم الحكومه انتخاب الرئيس همم
احيانا تشكيلات داخليه في لبنان يكون فيها
تدخل خارجي ولا تتم من دون رضا خارجي
لماذا ارجوك باختصار
هلا لا باختصار يعني لبنان هو دوله صغيره
تتعرض وتتاثر بكل ما يحيط بها من من
ديناميات تحصل على المستوى السياسي
والامني والعسكري والاقتصادي وهذا منذ
تاريخ نشوء لبنان منذ اكثر مئه عام ولكن
الرساله الاساس اليوم انه نحنا المجتمع
الدولي وحتى المجتمع العربي يريد ان يساعد
ولكن علينا ان نساعد الفصله لن يتدخل احد
من ناحيه وضع يعني اتفاق للبنان ويقول روح
انتخب هذا الرئيس او ذاك الرئيس يجب ان
نقوم احنا ك- قوه موجوده قوه سياسيه وقوه
في المجتمع على الحوار من بعضها البعض
لاصلاح بيتنا الداخلي وعلى راس هذه
الاصلاحات يبدا بانتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه
هذا هو المطلوب وهذا ياتي بناء على حوارات
وعلى نقاشات يجب ان تحصل بين كل القوه
السياسيه اذا نحن مفكرين انه سننتظر القوه
الدوليه او بعض القوه الاخرى تقول لنا هذا
هو الاسم روح تنتخبوه هذا هو تبسيط لما
يعني كيفيه تعمل هذه الدول خاصه في هذه
اللحظه التي نحن فيها في العالم والصراعات
الموجوده والقضايا العالميه الموجوده التي
تبعد كثير من الدول عن لبنان وعن مشاكل
لبنان انه امر داخلي اكيد تاثر بالخارج
وتاثر بالاقليم نتاثر بما يحدث ولكن يجب
ان يكون هذا جزء اساسي واصلاح بيت من
الداخل الذي يبدا بانتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه
طيب وهذا ما لم يحصل والتجارب السابقه تدل
ربما على العكس ذلك دائما كانت تدخل
للخارجي هو الذي ياتي بالرئيس او حتى
بالحكومات لكن اود ان اتوقف عن نقطه همم
لها علاقه بالترسيم ترسيم الحدود البحريه
بين لبنان واسرائيل هذا امر في ظل كل
مشاكل لبنان تم- لان كانت هناك اراده
خارجيه همم بالفعل ولبنان استجاب بشكل او
باخر مع العلم انه يقول قد اخذ كامله
حقوقه التي طلب بها ماذا يدل ذلك
هذا يدل انه عندما يتم توافق في لبنان بين
القوه السياسيه نستطيع ان ننجز وانجزنا
ايضا الانتخابات وهذا السهره يمكن على
التقرير الجزر الانتخابات النيابيه بدون
اي تدخل في هذه الانتخابات وجرت بشكل
الديمقراطي همم اتت بقتل واتت بعده يعني
كما ذكرت تقرير بادت اقليات همم لم يحصل
احد على اكثريه وهذا اشاره جيده على طريقه
اداره العمليه الانتخابيه التي حدثت في من
قبل الحكومه فيعني بعض الامور عندما نتفق
بين بعض البعض عندما يصبح اهداف واضحه وكل
القوى السياسيه ترضى انه نمشي بهذه نحو
هذه الاهداف تنجح في لبنان ننجح اكيد ضمن
همم يعني همم احتضان خارجي احتضان العرب
ولكن نحن لا يجب ان نكون مقصرين عن هذه
الاتفاقات لبدايه الانتخاب رئيس وغيره
شكرا لك ناصر ياسين وزير البيئه اللبنانيه
في حكومه تصريف الاعمال من بيروت